hello and welcome to this video I let's
see I play to a play Alekhine's defense
[Music]
I've done that bit alone is what it's go
see five hour Qaddafi that have to do
with former Libyan dictator I hope not
and so play please I cannot take five
seconds why do you play record game then
he okay anyway so let's develop he
played in five there against my defrost
reply Wow see for its own an unusual way
of handling this that I got something
delivered to me
okay let me make a quick move and then
take this thing I take a while at the
neighbors Steve three a good move here
could be em let's do it okay so the
three went back so what's to do ninety
four he would absolutely need to play
night a three yeah I think I think I'll
do that that and that secures my own but
to make sure that my night on before
will stave it's not easy firm to develop
pieces him i day three how do I continue
this Queen a4 in some cases I have
Bishop d7 how do I continue this
position maybe Queen to d7 yeah Queen a4
is prevented and this one yeah if I
check he will take and play the Queen to
e2 then I don't have a particularly
great continuation however
however hmm I wonder if I can do
something something more more forcefully
in this position it really looks as if
I'm can't prevent him from canceling
maybe that would be would be quite nice
h4 h5 is that oh it could be an idea rly
immediately attackers his structure damn
his crew has absolutely no squares well
III but this move my head Bishop g4 awk
win ce6
adds also a move that has to go up G 1
then this looks absolutely absolutely
terrible can I can I do even more like
windy form threatening Queen Eve form
doesn't do that much you should G form
you will have to go good to be three it
let's do that they don't want to spend a
super long time you know I probably
would be better with the most moves and
on time is one scenario how you can do
such a game where why does basically am
yeah running out of moves
soonish so g5
g5 open everything up it's not it's not
super convincing though h4 is the
alternative iam let's go h4
yeah I can even go h3 sent it back this
is actually not bad yeah it's it's let's
do the cell that's a funny position
those pawns on h3 and d3 totally limit
the white pieces so um how do we how do
we finish this a Knight to g4 l would be
cool so let's go right here to f5 to
deform what exactly is he doing against
it
[Music]
not much it seems
so you can take on f3 here not bad or 26
and check the night I mean it has no
square there's no square to go to I will
leave without dropping Luke
yeah it's a real disaster
Queen d13 basically nothing nothing else
and then you have a couple of things
that you can do not quite sure what I'm
actually playing because everything
looks good
he's almost stalemated him can have in
many of his pieces I think really one I
will probably play something like f6 or
so to open it even more on g5
yeah there were many questionable let's
say decisions by white in this game
now it takes this time didn't have five
seconds to wait for my move but now he's
taking his time and it's completely lost
okay I'm taking this Queen takes the 294
that should end the game
light takes that takes d4 there screen G
to check intermediate
take back proposition no no I mean it's
completely lost anyway that that's
really a waste of time I'm sorry okay so
let's say we look them and what happened
in this game and okay just give me it
says zero zero zero maybe I have no
don't I have some mistakes and probably
there were ways to win it quicker so um
the first strange move actually comes
here five is already a little bit
questionable simply because it gets to
this gets to a position that you would
normally see from reality
Cal Cal yeah where I'm a tempo up I've
got this in one move and therefore it's
kind of it's a bit out of place iam what
usually takes you on d5 or plates 93 and
both of those are still fairly normal
and get probably equal ish okay Bishop
f5 yeah now c4 is is a bit bit weird I
think she probably just developed with
Knight f3 the engine wants me to take on
Sequoia show this this is a good
alternative that sets pretty clear um
yeah that was when the doorbell rang is
roughly around here it made a quick
decision now g4 it's not bad but maybe
this is better here because there are
weaknesses on half-opened file now and
it takes this night sorry six yeah it's
probably better right in 396 the
officially - it's just bad chef you have
to go d3
because I'm sending it back now night
before that forces the night to a3 as on
c2 was such a big threat and now erh
five or Queen d7 27 s1 at play g3 and h5
is the most aggressive move we are
directly trying to use this
uncoordinated state of whites position
so H v 9h form yeah not great but it is
it is pretty awful anyway in each form
now the engine wants to take on H form
and continue this with law yeah but this
is this is even eating Louis now a night
h6 is a hazard oops has a very clear
plan and I don't think you can do much
about it
9f5 mistake
yeah a6 was even stronger Abbott okay I
mean at minus five is enough Bishop
takes f3
how can something like this but I can -
seven again minus seven is enough -
losing the house
yet it's really and now this opening
play is not very the action be
recommended unity fibers probably
slightly problematic already okay guys
thanks for watching